let's talk to people in the audience why
not uh we do calls now via discord you
can find us at davidpakman.com
discord
join the discord almost 15 000 now on
the discord
and uh we can we can chat let's do it
let's
start today
um with
oh how about uh i don't know
it's so tough to say how about ronnie
from new york you are first on today
hey david can you hear me okay yes i can
hey i was just curious are we ever gonna
see producer lewis again on the show
as an employee or just like as a guest
appearance
uh maybe just as a guest oh yeah yeah
he's welcome any time to my streams i've
even invited him on a couple times but
he's been you know very tied up with
either mowing his lawn or video gaming
or different things so it's hard to find
just that perfect time for lewis to
appear but i actually i had lunch with
him yesterday and he's doing well
he's soon going to be shifting over to
an electric vehicle going fully electric
and uh yeah he's no no no other news
really with lewis but he's welcome
anytime
okay well that's all i had to ask thank
you all right thanks ronnie there's a
there's ronnie from new york with
a very strong question